[Music]
what do you got to do time for you to
see the world P the
button sweet and loving God hello
everyone and welcome to the Fandango Big
Ticket interview and I'm here with the
cast and filmmakers behind the color
purple first of all I have to start of
course to my left to you Miss Oprah
Winfrey because I wanted to ask you this
is a time that I think folks are going
to be excited not only to see this film
but to see it with their families at
Christmas and I love the fact that a new
generation is going to get to make new
memories around this incredible film I'd
love for you to talk about why you felt
now is the time well what I want to talk
about is that you can go to Fandango and
get the
ticket that's what I want to talk about
what I want to talk about and Blitz can
tell you this is true that way back in
February in one of the first earliest
meetings we had I said look I want to
make the tickets my favorite thing let's
figure out a way we can get tickets in
the hands of people so that you can have
them in a little box and I'd like a
little bow on them and Fandango you came
through so thank you very much and I
think what's so wonderful about um being
able to have the tickets and give to
your friends all kinds of friends give
them to everybody in your office because
this movie is for everybody who has a
heart and wants it open
and I feel that you know that no matter
where you come from whatever your race
or place is in life that the experience
of having the aperture of your heart
open so that you feel Joy you feel
lifted you feel forgiveness you feel a
sense of healing for yourself that's why
this is the perfect Christmas movie that
is why it's for the Christmas season and
we wanted it on Christmas Day we we
wanted this position because we thought
thought it would uplift people yes I
also love that we're getting this
musical version because Miss Fantasia um
the role our miss cely that you played
on Broadway you're also bringing it here
to audiences on screen and they're going
to get to experience Joy which I really
want folks to remember about this and a
lot of that Joy happens in the mind of R
cely I would love for you to talk about
how this new interpretation lives in
that world of magical realism and how
you got to play with with that aspect of
cely which not a lot of folks maybe can
see in previous versions and that's why
I said yes to the part because he gave
her an imagination playing it on
Broadway she didn't have one and that's
probably why it was so heavy you know it
was it was so heavy she wasn't allowed
to express how she got through all of
that stuff um and she code switches sely
plays with everybody she's with mis
Sophia Haro shook Avery that's a lot to
carry so the fact that he gave her an
imagination and allow her to live and
and is allowing young people young girls
young men to see that no matter where
you are it starts in the mind you plant
the seed if you want to see yourself in
a better place plant the seed and I'm
going to say like Miss o said this this
time with sely taught me so much of
course I'm Wiser now I'm a mom now of
three got a doggy so we're going to add
Lola that's
four you know married I'm I'm I'm in a
different place I see things totally
different and I guess I was afraid of
going back into cely and seeing the same
thing but that was different totally
different Her Imagination allowed me to
play a little more allowed me to be able
to carry you know all that I needed to
carry playing with my castmates and the
roles that they were playing um and it
allowed my heart like she said to open
cuz I always had one but it was through
the
years broken broken P so much stuff so
much stuff and I wanted it to be open
again playing sely this time allowing
her to be my life coach allow my heart
to open again and that's all I ever want
it thank you for that I'm okay no more
cry for
me um Mr Blitzer just being here we got
tissues on the table I have to ask ask
you sir how did y'all keep dry eyes
because I will say every time I'm with
this group I feel the emotion but I will
say the best part of it is the fact that
on top of that we also get the colorful
vibrancy that you put on set and that it
came from I think from the first moment
that you thought about doing this
project and so I'd love for you to talk
about how your work as a visual artist
really was the Bible for every single
person that you ended up bringing on set
for this experience wow um you know I'm
originally from Ghana you know and you
know I grew up around Vivid color I mean
if you see African fabric it's some of
the most Vivid and my mom had a stack of
that fabric you know and so and so I
know color it's it's it's how we move
and and and I I really was made a choice
very early that we weren't going to
create a film that felt drab and felt
seep your tone and and
desaturated um because I I find it it's
a false uh way in which people see the
past because they often looking at
photographs that have survived several
years which are obviously cpia tone and
obviously black and white and so me Dan
laen Francine my costumer Paul Asberry
our job first job was to say we're going
to push through these photographs and
arve where people lived in color and
that color was vibrant it was it was
alive
and that's kind of where we really begun
but I also think that in a way
psychologically it brings an exuberance
to the audience right when Sugar's
coming on that barge I mean that's still
one of my favorite just frames you know
that red dress and that blue steel blue
you know atmosphere behind you and those
lamps that is the kind a visual that is
inviting and I think for a story that
oscillates between Joy and Pain
the visuals that are inviting become the
bridge that allow you to stay through
the difficult things because even when
the circumstances are not beautiful we
are a beautiful people thank you I had
to drop that jam yes
bars Miss taji P Henson ma'am a lot of
that joy and a lot of that beauty comes
through with your portrayal of Suge
Avery who literally jumps off the screen
from the minute we get to see her but I
really love the idea that as many
credits as all of you have done but
especially with your career that you've
done to this point you got to explore
new things with Suge Avery I'd love for
you to talk about because we've seen you
do a lot we've seen cookie we've seen
we've seen Benjamin Button what did you
bring to this portrayal um that you got
to play with for the first time the
singing um because I play you know I I
re you know a lot of the research for me
sometimes start with the name and so
when you when you name a character Suge
that means something and I've played a
Suge for in Hustle and Flow that Su was
more like cely you know a diamond in the
rough and so this Su was big and she was
like you know she's the cookie of the
1920s you know and what another thing
that's really in particular like you
they always say Heroes you don't some
Heroes don't wear capes you know I had
one journalist say she was like an alien
coming down from space but you have to
realize this is one uh this is the first
gener this is the next the first
generation of free slaves right so for
her to be so bold and and Her
Imagination her imagin where she lived
in her head to be able to be the one to
get away and go out there and do
something and make something of herself
that is whoa like well I don't think
I've ever played a character like that
before but I guess for me it would be
the the singing like the singing and to
be in this industry for more than 20
years and to be my age 53 and still be
able to surprise my
fans I couldn't have I couldn't have
dreamed this you know what I mean like
like you said God we our we're too our
brains are too small you know a bigger
dream and that's why you have to
surrender you have to surrender and so
that's what I did I I totally
surrendered to this woman and she taught
me so much about myself I am kind of
like a clut in real life and I was
watching the fancy scene and I saw my
hand go up and how it came up so
elegantly under your chin and lifted I
said what where did that come from what
are these
things I didn't even know that who that
woman yeah I was like yeah exactly I was
like what I don't even know how to do it
again you know so that's the beautiful
thing about what we do because it's it's
literally really spiritual you know to
allow our bodies to be a vessel for
these characters to tell their stories
um that's why you have to protect your
space you have to protect your energy
and I think we we all know that because
we do this and that's why we were so
protective of each other on set you know
this woman here having to carry all of
that I I'm a leading woman I know what
it takes to need support I know how to
support and so there were times when I
would see her you know we do a scene and
I would like play with her you know what
I mean and get out of it you know cuz to
take on your when you leave you got to
go home and deal with your us being
black women kids family you don't have
time and space to take on the character
and take them home cuz your kids and
your family don't understand they're not
in the business you know so any chance I
could I would try to make everybody
laugh or you know try to lift it up I
think we all did that we had Church on
set we did the Electric Slide the first
day with Miss obber Winfrey the Electric
Slide yeah original okay the original
yes okay clarification not the chaa SL
not the don't get it confused I can see
folks getting fancy um I I'm looking
across here um and I'm seeing the two
women that introduce us in this version
of The Color Purple you guys are
literally our opening scenes in Felicia
and hiy um the chemistry and camaraderie
between you two from before you even
spoke a word just watching you walk
together like sisters I know that was
something that y'all built on set but
I'd love for for both of you to sort of
talk about the sort of camaraderie also
as actors because Felicia mentioned how
you coming off The Little Mermaid you
were able to do what Taraji was already
saying really build each other up in
these moments to where it was not just
on screen you guys also had to build
that off screen as well and I'll start
with you hie oh wow well I guess I'll
say for me um there's such power in
working with black women and black
people people in general we love you
guys but black women black women are
truly like the force of what keeps me
going and leads me so for this
opportunity that I got to do I was so
glad to be partnered with somebody that
I had to build that Sisterhood and it
felt like a beautiful journey of us
together togetherness of Hope and um
something that I really loved about
Netty is that
she's a symbol of Hope for the film
throughout the whole thing even when
she's gone you know C's holding on to
the hope of where she might have gone if
she's okay is she dead is she alive and
so I really just tried to relate that
sort of feeling in my performance of
netti and making her I guess just stick
um so that she can stay throughout the
whole film and people's memories um but
I feel like Felicia was my anchor in in
being able to do that um and it was just
it was like so cool to be able to work
with an amazing person like her who's
just like so loving and it feels like
you're just hanging out with your friend
on set and um yeah made it it really
easy and Felicia I'd love for you to
talk about that because I know you were
like yeah I know you're The Little
Mermaid on the first day I mean it's
intimidating at the time I feel like you
had the number one song you know that's
just I feel like it was like the number
one song in the world and so I walk into
this environment with someone who to me
was such a pro and such a professional I
was just like how am I going to meet her
level but I think we both felt that we
had a responsibility to them to the
characters and especially to Fantasia
and then Sierra who's going to take over
because we really want it to really to
really sit with people people to really
feel when they get reunited so we really
had to build a bond and I am so
appreciative cuz I think in the way of
like teraji what you did for for me
every day on set was you would tell me I
was beautiful every time I walked out of
that trailer I would see that and I oh
my God and it just meant a lot I don't
know if you I don't think we ever really
talked about like how I struggled with
beauty and how when this role came about
I was like oh it's sely okay she's not
the netti you know I want to be more
like netti and you gave me space and
permission to just really see sely as a
hero and I hope that people really take
that away from this film that cely is
the protagonist but she is a
hero amen
yeah I mean in so many ways this this
movie turns black women into superheroes
of Our Own Story um and you can't have a
superhero though without a villain and
so I maybe maybe maybe our Mister comes
around if these are the sunshine he's
the storm clouds but Mr Coleman Domingo
so for folks that haven't had a chance
to see your incredible portrayal of Bard
Rus and I encourage them to do so but
yes it is remarkable and just compliment
so much to what you do on screen here
but talk about that Duality for you as
an actor going from playing this
incredibly inspirational character to a
man who is literally the detriment of so
many of his people around him and and
also maybe how your journey was as an
actor on set with with those two things
sort of playing with
you well I I thank you um I I I did
Rustin first yeah and then I think I had
a two we break and I started preparing
myself while I was finishing up up
Rustin for this and I think I've just
always been that person that believes
just like I'm sure we all believe that
it's all human and light and dark it
it's all part of the same thing you you
have all that in you I know that I'm
somebody who wakes up every morning who
I'm hopeful I think um I think I was
raised with the belief that the world
was there to do me more good than ill um
I believe in humanity I believe in love
energy I think I'm a spiritual person
but I also understand the darkness I
understand the gifts that I've been
given but what would happen if I didn't
have those gifts I think that that's
what we all try to experience as actors
to look at the look at the flip side I
knew when I would come from playing this
person who Rustin who was one of my
personal Heroes to actually playing
someone that I had questions about
someone who I thought well how can
someone do something like that to
someone what what what is it that maybe
I even have inside of me have to look at
as being human you know in every single
way like this person I had to find ways
to love Mister that's the only way I can
play him is to find out well what are
his dreams and his aspirations what
happens when he doesn't get it what
beliefs were poured into him that are
really the antithesis of what actually
is happening how these women are involve
evolving how his ideas about women um
I'm such a feminist and I always want to
make sure that I I have space for women
and make sure that they have what they
need and I knew that I needed that as
well to actually be Mister to actually
play Mister I needed to be that be that
feminist and looked after my co-stars
every single day and make sure that they
were held and they they they had what
they needed and also to look at build
the arc of my character as well to make
sure for me to look at their evolution
how smart they are and how cely you know
is the one to um to give Grace to her
oppressor and I think that's powerful I
think that says a lot that says a lot
about who this woman is and I think the
capacity of women and what they hold and
what they do I mean I'm I I'm that's
just me in my beliefs I believe women
are always much more involved than men I
felt for Mister in a way that I hadn't
in the multiple takes multiple takes I I
I had seen since we started this process
that moment when he's on the porch with
the flower and holding it and says sh
Ain't No Hoe which which Su ain't no ho
she she she just had a wild heart like
me I mean I felt that in a way that I
had not it pierced me in a way that I
had not and I thought wow that's another
dimension to mister he's trying to say
look she was somebody who I wished I
could be she just has a wild heart I
mean Oh I thought that was so
beautifully done and I saw it
differently last night I was just going
to say that was also your choice which I
mean it's another thing you know just
from a director's point of view you know
it's collaborative Spirit right when you
come up to me and you go Blitz
I think from what happened last night
with Suge Mist have a flower and would I
go man this guy is good yeah you know I
was because when sh comes she she
changes the house there's possibility
again so I know that like you know I had
that flower I thought like oh that's
he's just you feel a little bit of that
color tender beautiful but you actually
connected the dots because when you cook
that crappy meal oh no when actually
when sely fixed your mistake Put the
flower on the plate first actually
connected but but I do want to say I
mean that's the beauty of this process
is like remembering that film making is
deeply collaborative yes truly and again
if you're the director you're merely the
conductor everybody's a master of the
instrument nobody will ever know the
character better than you do and so you
know I really encourage like that spirit
that we built where you know please seek
that out as you as you work as you can
especially our our newer Cadre always
seek directors who would trust your
instrument and trust that your they're
you're a master of your instrument and
will allow you because those little
nuances that by the way everybody came
up to me you came up to me Holly you're
like Blitz I feel like M knows this I
mean h netti knows there a predator in
the house she will not walk around with
a towel because I think that's how it
was scripted when you're when you're on
the porch and I was like duh she knows
the character right and it and and by
the way every single person came up to
me and goes that thing if we tweaked it
this way you know what I mean and that's
for me is the beauty of the symphony is
is knowing and trusting that everybody
is a master of the
instrument no I just have to say it's
all first chairs here like let's be real
everybody is at the top of the orchestra
first
chairs only oh look at that look at that
all first chair trying to keep up with
y'all uh
uh including our you know Julie juliard
educated uh Harpo over here sir let's
gohe and talk about it sir because again
I want to make sure that folks
understand the joy of this piece and the
joy that you fought for in this piece
because we get to see Harpo go to work
and I love not only what that scene
means for the character but let's be
real they put they put Corey in some
nice outfits with a hammer it was it was
really
nice the shoulder rolls
shoulder roll you like that shoulder
roll that shoulder roll going to get him
into some trouble see oh that shoulder
roll I'd love get him in
trouble okay stop thirsting over
Court um I would love for you to talk
about the work you put into the work
song oh well um the work of the work
song honestly Haro for me is a um he's
an he's an Observer he's a quiet I think
he's an empath I think he's somebody who
feels deeply and uh it's not a world uh
that necessarily allowed him the space
to do that but he made the space and I
think he was empowered to make the space
by his woman by by Sophia um because he
sees in the same way that you guys were
just talking about how you see that in
Su I think har sees that in Sophia and
allows himself the freedom to go there
whereas you might not have done that and
he makes the decision to change he makes
the decision to bring to build um and
then we're also talking about L Gosa Jr
who plays my
grandfather
he allow he he wants me to build on that
land for my wife you know and what is
that about a the generational the thing
that skips you know the gaps right
because our
grandparents um and versus our parents
and and how that that parental trauma
that that trauma in general is passed
down but but Haro makes a decision to
break that cycle and to change it and
he's given a song and I was like please
Blitz give me a
song please I was like I was like I was
like I I would love for Harpo to be able
to to to let his voice sing you know um
he may not know how to he's awkward and
may not know how to do it in other ways
but but he knows how to let his voice
sing for the for the people and the
things he wants and and um uh Blitz
graciously uh well he wrote it and and
he gave it to me about five we were
doing the roundt the reading table read
and everybody was there or or on the
zooms and the um Everybody sitting there
just waiting five minutes before Blitz
comes up he's like let me talk to you
and he gives me haro's work song and he
sings it for me he's like cuz you know
he's a excellent musician and and he
sings it for me and uh and then he was
like go and then just and he just left
me with it um but but that was the spark
that kind of uh allowed me the freedom
to go and to play and then Fatima's
incredible team and choreography um
Talk uhhuh uhhuh um also blitzes vocals
by the way
um
yes yeah um but it's a but it's a it's a
joy to be able to um to have that
freedom to have that and and also the
joy of Music black music and where it
comes from you know we start singing we
hear a beat and all of a sudden we you
know our voices are in it and and and
that goes back years and years so it was
a blessing to be able to um Infuse this
this movie with that because that's what
this movie is it leaves you with joy and
their relationship truly truly
everything they fight through Harpo and
Sophia to where they get to I truly
think is a testament to love and you
smile at the end like even last night I
just was like after all of that we win
you know um smile and also cheer because
that is definitely a clap break for
folks that don't know it's a real
showstopper another showstopper however
is courtesy of our Sophia Soph Sophia
Sophia such a pretty name Paul I will
say this um women don't know that you're
about to give them the anthem for when
they're fed up but the uh previews have
been out there on it I would love for
you to talk about what you're excited
for women are going to do with hell no
what women are going to do with this
moment and how much you had fun doing
that knowing what women were going to do
with this moment yeah I had so much fun
doing hillo and having those sisters
back me up and also Blitz giving me the
freedom to express her Freedom the way
that I wanted to I remember the scene
with um her coming through the door in
the house and naturally you know one
would just open the door but I told
Bliss I was like no I think Sophia would
kick this door open and he rigged it for
me so that I could kick it open you know
even with the the the painting or this
picture thank you of Sophia and Harpo
was like I think she throw it in the
water
they rigged it so I could throw it in
the water I was like this is awesome but
that's exactly what this song should be
for so many other women or all the women
and men too but women we thinking about
women
um this is the women's Anthem um you
know because Sophia does represent
strength and power and and knowing who
you are and standing firm in who you are
she was a woman way ahead of her time
and so I'm really excited for women to
feel that I think it gave me so much
more freedom to even say to such an
esteemed director who worked with
Beyonce and you know black is King to
get to say this is what I need and own
that you know what I mean playing this
role and and Beyond hell no which will
become the woman's Anthem okay but
beyond that I do feel like people that
will come to see this film will find
their song whether that's through Su
Avery's coming to town and empower that
has or or your what's your what's your
big number um push the button the
freedom that that song has or I'm here
which has been my freedom song um so I'm
excited for women to feel that and not
just black women all women I do see even
15-year-old girls getting to say hell no
to being bullied you know or whatever
that is if you're older and and you you
just want to get out of a job I feel
like um this will be your song
thank you between that and break my soul
we got it thank
y'all I want to thank you all so much
and I want to remind everyone that
tickets for the color purp on sale now
and you can buy them for friends okay
not just your own you can also buy them
for friends at
Fandango everybody yes thank
you